bonsoir nous sommes le 10 mars 2015
bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7-8 politique
premier tour du scrutin départemental
dans exactement 12 jours 21 cantons dans
les Yvelines 5 que nous suivons plus
particulièrement autour de 50 ans en
Yvelines et nous allons aujourd'hui
faire un point sur cette campagne qui ne
mobilise pas beaucoup les électeurs les
sondages évoquent une courte majorité
est 53% des Français qui s'y
intéresseraient et pourtant les enjeux
sont réels car il s'agit de désigner ce
qui éviteront dans le domaine social
dans la gestion des collèges ou encore
des routes pour les partis politiques
c'est aussi un test important ainsi dans
les Yvelines l'umperait réaliser le
Grand Chelem le Parti socialiste
conserver des cantons à gauche et puis
le Front national obtenu et enfin des
élus un tour d'horizon complet avec ce
sujet de Catherine zulator
un enjeu politique pour ces élections
départementales pour cela les parties
n'ont pas ménagé leur peine à commencer
par l'UMP qui dès le mois de décembre
avait annoncé son union avec l'UDI pour
débit nommant commun pour le parti de
Nicolas Sarkozy une ambition réalisée le
Grand Chelem dans le département que les
21 cantons soient gagnés par la droite
nous avons réussi à faire une très belle
unité
du centre jusqu'au modem de toutes les
sensibilités de la droite qui sont
réunis aujourd'hui pour gagner des
cantons qui sont jusqu'à présent réputés
in-gagnables je pense à Trappes je pense
à Guyancourt nous sommes le parti du
projet et j'invite tous les électeurs à
ne pas voter pour les autres partis qui
n'ont soit pas de projet soit qui font
campagne sur le rejet pour le Parti
socialiste l'objectif conserver des
cantons aujourd'hui plaisir Maurepas
trappe Montigny Guyancourt sont détenus
par des élus de la gauche ils sont neufs
assiégés au conseil général sur 39 élus
on souhaite garder le maximum de cantons
que l'on détient et on en a pas
énormément dans le département c'est
aussi la survie du débat démocratique
dans le département qui est en jeu
l'ambition c'est déjà de porter nos
valeurs c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas
d'inhibition on porte des valeurs qui
sont fortes qui sont faites de tolérance
qui se s'appuient sur la devise
républicaine et dans la période c'est
d'actualité la gauche qui n'a pas réussi
à faire l'union sur tous les cantons
Europe Écologie Les Verts s'associent
dans certains cas avec le bouton de
gauche on souhaite le rassemblement le
plus large possible de la gauche mais
sur des contenus qui sont clairement
anti-austérité en rupture avec les
politiques qui sont menées aujourd'hui
le gouvernement
pas avoir des socialistes qui nous
rejoignent qu'effectivement et
particulièrement sur 50 ans ça se
décline plutôt sur des rassemblements
avec Europe Écologie Les Verts qui se
situe eux et vraiment dans cette rupture
vis-à-vis de l'austérité ce qui est
important pour les électeurs c'est
qu'ils se retrouvent dans les programmes
qu'on propose et donc nous on a un
programme qui est différent de celui du
Parti socialiste donc ça nous paraît
logique de le présenter de le proposer
aux voix ce qui est très important pour
nous c'est d'arriver à ne pas avoir un
département des Yvelines qui soit 100% à
droite ou au Front National et pour se
faire la seule façon c'est de
remobiliser les électeurs de gauche qui
ne vont plus voter l'abstention les
parties la craignent tout comme le vote
du Front national dans les Yvelines de
parties de Marine Le Pen présente un
binôme de candidat dans chacun des
cantons c'est une première et le
président départemental ne cache ses
ambitions nous voulons gagner le
département nous sommes scandalisés par
la manière dont ce de ce département est
dirigé l'espace des choses on est le
premier parti de France ça bouge sans
arrêt on sent que les
diguigs seront petit à petit à force de
nous traiter d'antirer républicains les
gens n'y croient plus il y a bien
longtemps autre partie présent pour ces
élections debout la France le parti de
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan présente des
candidats dans 8 des 21 cantons le
message principal c'est de demander aux
Français reprend les cours je reprends
les conférences on peut faire de la
politique intelligemment dans l'intérêt
des Français hors des autres parties qui
depuis 40 ans vous baladent et ici c'est
parce que des parties vous ont mis en
colère qu'après on vote pour les
extrêmes ce qui est jamais une solution
et qui a d'autres gens qui sont des
patriotes qui sont convaincus qui
peuvent les défendre le premier tour des
élections départementales a lieu le 22
mars la campagne officielle vient de
démarrer ce lundi
et pour réaliser son Grand Chelem dans
les Yvelines l'UMP FEDER ces troupes
avec l'ensemble de la droite et du
centre également modem et udi la semaine
dernière à meeting commun était organisé
avec l'ensemble des candidats une grande
messe l'objectif dévoiler le programme
commun mais aussi désigné les principaux
adversaires abstention et front
nationales pierre Bédié président
sortant du conseil départemental et
d'ailleurs opposé sur son canton de
manteau mère frontiste de
Mantes-la-Ville Cyril note et la
formation de Marine Le Pen ne cesse de
répéter à travers le département son
aversion envers celui qui fut secrétaire
d'État chargé des programmes immobiliers
de la justice sous Jacques Chirac
je crains que dans le département des
Yvelines beaucoup de deuxième tour une
majorité de deuxième tour soit umpfn et
donc avec des risques de chute notre
objectif c'est le grand chelem mais la
faiblesse du PS qui nous faisait espérer
le Grand Chelem ne peut nous permettre
de le faire que si nous arrivons à
contenir un Front National qui est
démagogique et pas très opérationnel du
côté du PS à présent mène aussi
campagnes en espérant conserver quelques
fiefs Montigny et trappes font partie
des cantons prioritaires un meeting de
la Fédération des socialistes des
Yvelines prévues vendredi 13 mars
prochain à Mantes-la-Jolie en présence
de Benoît Hamon et Françoise descan
grenier est député des Yvelines ainsi
que d'André Silvestre conseiller général
sortant un mot des sondages à présent on
le sait Manuel Valls attirer il y a
quelques jours la sonnette d'alarme
Quentin improbable raz-de-marée du parti
de Marine Le Pen au départementale dans
les intentions de vote recensées par un
sondage au daxa pour RTL et publiée
début de semaine le Front national
obtiendrait un score de 31% premier tour
devant l'UMP et l'UDI 29%, le PS n'étant
qu'à 20% le FN pourrait donc gagner au
moins un département le Var le Vaucluse
le gars les rôles la somme laine le
Pas-de-Calais ou encore l'Oise sont
évoqués dans les Yvelines cela sera plus
compliqué même si le parti présente des
candidats dans les 21 cantons vous le
savez depuis la semaine dernière TV Phil
vous propose des débats avec les
candidats aux élections départementales
des bas à revoir en intégralité sur
notre site Internet grâce au replay je
vous propose néanmoins d'en écouter
quelques extraits tout d'abord
concernant le canton de Trappes ou la
gauche ne parvient pas à faire l'union
ce qui pourrait à l'handicaper pour
conserver son siège les candidats sur ce
secteur sont revenus en plateau sur
quelques-unes de leur proposition à côté
le premier tour de table en quelques
mots et pour les électeurs les raisons
de votre candidature à cette élection on
va commencer avec vous Janine Marie
pourquoi vous présenter pour un nouveau
mandat alors on va présenter pour un
nouveau mandat pour poursuivre ce qui a
été entamé sur la ville et sur le canton
puisque le canton était quand on vit là
c'est maintenant voilà
donc encore plus passionnant pour suivre
ce qui a été commencé peaufiner
certaines choses parce qu'on s'aperçoit
que lorsqu'on a des contrats sur une
ville avec des objectifs à 3 ans la
société évoluant rapidement il est il
faut être réactif et quelquefois à
intervenir en disant non là on peut plus
continuer ça et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire sur la prévention
spécialisée et puis ensuite il y a aussi
un autre dossier qui est important et
qui va changer la ville de Trappes c'est
l'enterrement de la de la nationale 10
ou le Conseil général intervient de
façon importante en entrée en sortie de
de cette enterrement et puis toute
l'aménagement du plateau Oumma Urba ou
également le Conseil général est
concerné par le pont cachain qui est une
route départementale et du trade vous
voulez surveiller le bon déroulement de
ces différents
candidature ecoutez d'abord un
effondrement
massif bien sûr dans les communes de nos
moyens donc les 36000 maires de France
bien sûr ont d'autant plus envie d'aller
chercher d'autres moyens notamment
conseil général devant la situation bon
deuxièmement bon les grands projets nous
c'est emploi parce que c'est la première
attente donc il s'agit de mieux
coordonner peut-être les moyens de la
casquille du conseil général vous voyez
le développement économique bon et puis
de simplifier l'état de procédure bon
pour pour créer de l'emploi mais je te
dis je suis prudent sur les promesses on
a vu nos collègues socialistes ils
avaient promis un million d'emplois ils
ont détruit un million d'emplois toutes
catégories donc prudence bien sûr mais
mobilisation sur l'emploi deuxièmement
l'éducation et l'encours est plutôt
considéré comme un modèle en France même
à donc de l'innovation pédagogique pour
les enfants donc bien sûr on aimerait en
faire profiter trap on est moins faire
profiter également la verrière avec bien
sûr le soutien du Conseil général
notamment au niveau des collèges pour
qu'il y ait une continuité et puis
dernier point la famille bien sûr avec
toute l'aspect social autour de la
famille qu'il faut renforcer sur une
valeur qui est très importante en France
la problématique est celle d'un constat
le Conseil général des Yvelines et le
département des Yvelines est un des
départements les plus riches de France
le deuxième le plus riche en
Île-de-France et en termes d'action
sociale qui est une de ces compétences
majeures il pratique la régression
sociale et alors que les demandes et les
besoins augmentent donc ça c'est une
raison importante on constate qu'il y a
un très grand défi des gens par rapport
à la politique et donc nous on pense que
il y a une ouverture possible sur une
autre politique réellement de gauche et
c'est pour ça qu'on a participé à ce
rassemblement avec Europe Écologie les
verres notamment aujourd'hui bien
franchement je sais pas qui est autour
de cette table peut savoir quelles
seront les compétences du département
demain à l'issue de ces élections parce
que certes le gouvernement qui avait
annoncé la suppression enfin je parle de
Manuel Valls Premier ministre qui avait
annoncé la suppression de du département
à l'horizon 2020 et revenu en arrière
parce qu'il s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait des élections sont les cantons
enfin tout ça est encore en discussion
je crois que les Français ils ont ils en
ont un peu souper de de l'alternance
gauche droite gauche droite qui finit
par nous endormir c'est un effet un peu
hypnotique non nous on propose une
alternative et une alternative crédible
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a des élus qui
sont implantés localement dans les
conseils municipaux sans expérience
on la gagne fogos mais c'est pas une
garantie
elle se gagne dans les assemblées elle
se gagne sur le terrain Nicolas
pour ma conclusion donc nous on propose
une alternative aux Français là on a un
grand danger devant nous c'est
l'abstentionnisme et donc moi je
souhaiterais attirer l'attention des
téléspectateurs là-dessus il faut qu'il
se mobilisent qu'ils
j'ai pas la prétention qui vote tous
pour nous mais qui s'exprime sur ce
scrutin mais qui s'exprime déjà parce
que c'est extrêmement important notre
démocratie est en danger et donc les
élections ne sont pas l'uniques moyen de
l'expression de cette démocratie mais
son état qu'il s'en saisisse et qui vote
pour se rassemblement que nous
représentons Europe Écologie Les Verts
le fond de gauche Parti communiste autre
débat que vous avez pu suivre sur TVfil
78 celui opposant les candidats qui se
présentent sur le canton de morpa
écoutez une partie de leurs échanges
autour de l'avenir du conseil
départemental rappelons qu'il y a encore
quelques mois il était question de la
disparition de ces assemblées
département mental et quand ce moment
même leurs compétences sont en
discussion à l'Assemblée
depuis deux ans on est engagé dans une
véritable révolution des structures du
pays
parfois un peu anarchique d'ailleurs
parce que il y a 6 mois on nous
annonçait la fin des départements on
voit très bien maintenant qu'après avoir
créé de très grandes régions en province
on ne pourra pas vraiment abandonner les
champs départemental mais en tout état
de cause l'Île-de-France quand même est
un cas un peu à part et différent et je
pense que en Île-de-France effectivement
on a besoin d'un échelon qui permette de
garder une proximité avec la population
et c'est vrai que le département
joue de ce point de vue un rôle qui est
tout à fait privilégié c'est un acteur
majeur de la vie quotidienne de chacun
d'entre nous parce que il est auprès des
communes lorsque on va s'adresser au
Centre Communal d'Action Sociale de sa
commune en réalité le véritable acteur
derrière c'est le conseil général parce
que c'est lui qui en matière de handicap
en matière de personnes âgées en matière
de jeunesse en matière de chômeur c'est
le Conseil Général qui est à la
manoeuvre derrière même si effectivement
le guichet ce sera peut-être le Centre
Communal d'Action Sociale il faut pas
transférer ses compétences vers les
intercommunalités qui vont d'ailleurs
s'agrandir alors aujourd'hui les
intercommunalités sont absolument pas
capables de prendre la relève du conseil
général il faudrait d'abord qu'elle soit
stabilisée ce qui est loin d'être le cas
je pense que le département a toute sa
raison d'être ne serait-ce que sur
l'aspect social
ils vendent Val l'a dit il a dit tout à
l'heure effectivement le Conseil général
à une compétence première qui est celle
du de l'action sociale et je crois que
la meilleure façon de garantir une
action sociale qui est commune à
l'ensemble des yvelinois c'est d'avoir
un organisme qui puisse mutualiser tout
ça en en une seule entité parce que
demain je pense de toute façon que les
les intercos n'ont pas la capacité
aujourd'hui de faire de l'action sociale
admettons que demain elle puisse le
faire rien ne garantit que sur
l'ensemble du département tel qu'il
existerait vous auriez une égalité de
traitement en termes d'action sociale
sur tout le territoire et l'action
sociale c'est quand même aider les plus
démunis les handicapés et il faut
absolument qu'il y ait un organisme qui
centralise tout ça et qui garantissent
un même service à tous cela me semble
extrêmement important il y a une réforme
territoriale est-ce que c'est le
département qui doit subsister est-ce
qu'on doit garder les départements
est-ce qu'on doit développer les interco
les régions etc je pense qu'il faut en
discuter et et pour en discuter
proprement il faudrait faire appel
justement la population la mettre au
courant et définir avec la population ce
qu'elle est la bonne distance quelle est
la bonne échelle les départements ils
ont été établis à l'époque pour être
accessible à en une journée à cheval bon
on n'est plus à l'époque du cheval on va
un petit peu plus vite on se déplace on
n'a pas les mêmes modes de transport on
n'a pas non plus les mêmes modes de
connexion on a l'informatique etc donc
je pense que c'est à redéfinir ça peut
être redéfini et on n'est pas obligé de
rester sur les frontières dans établies
il y a deux siècles mais par contre
il faut les définir avec une proximité
aux citoyenne or si on va vers des
interco très grandes si on va vers des
régions de plus en plus grandes qui sont
désirées par l'Europe mais qui ne sont
pas
celles que la population aurait demandé
je pense qu'on va à l'encontre de ce qui
est bon pour la population et donc on
perd de la démocratie l'aspect
démocratique l'aspect citoyenneté qui
pour nous est essentiel sur notre livre
c'est la base c'est la citoyenneté donc
on a vraiment on va à l'encontre de ce
qui est bon pour la population
actuellement donc
l'échelle canton ou interco c'est à peu
près la même échelle c'est pas la même
distance c'est pas le même découpage
mais c'est à peu près la même taille
pour moi c'est une bonne échelle
l'intercommunalité après il faut bien la
définir
mais après ça permet de connecter les
intercontrals donc c'est pas non moi ça
me paraît une bonne échelle aussi moi je
crois qu'il faut garder le rôle de la
commune et du département et ça c'est
important parce que il y a il faut la
proximité pour les tous les Français on
est en si on le but je pense d'ici 2020
de du nouveau du nouveau plan en fait
c'est intercommunalité hyper région et
Europe parce que il faut pas se leurrer
tout va vers l'Europe quand même si on
en arrive là c'est parce qu'il y a des
directives européennes derrière et on
veut faire en fait de nos départements
plutôt des États-Unis pour que ce
devienne des États-Unis européens et ça
nous nous sommes contre tout ça il faut
garder les rôles des communes des
régions et de l'état ça c'est des
départements et ça c'est primordial
on va perdre sinon toute notre ruralité
également tous nos artisans parce que
voilà c'est ça fait partie aussi tout ça
du département et
moi je suis plus dans cette directive là
autre extrait de ce débat redécouvrir en
intégralité sur notre site internet il
concerne l'aspect social c'est encore
aujourd'hui l'une des plus importantes
compétences des départements à La droite
majoritaire dans le département des
Yvelines jusqu'à présent se dit
satisfaite de son bilan ce n'est
forcément pas le cas de son opposition
de gauche
je crois qu'on peut être fier du bilan
d'ailleurs tout récemment encore on
disait que le Conseil général des
Yvelines était l'un des mieux gérés de
France c'était sur une antenne
concurrente comme on dit pas vraiment
local
le social par qui est le domaine
d'action numéro 1 du conseil général
c'est plus 60 % du budget qui est
consacré à l'aide sociale souvent
d'ailleurs sous fait sous forme d’être
personnel si c'est une allocation
personnalisée autonomie pour les
personnes âgées ça peut être des aides
pour les handicapés
évidemment tout le monde le connaît le
RSA le Conseil général est donc un
acteur majeur cela dit nous avons besoin
d'aller plus loin on constate notamment
qu'on a beaucoup de problèmes avec
l'insertion en réalité l'insertion ne
fonctionne pas bien certes on est dans
un contexte économique qui ne facilite
certainement pas la réinsertion des
chômeurs c'est clair si on avait un
marché de l'emploi dynamique ça se
passerait mieux néanmoins c'est quand
même une vraie difficulté
pour des phénomènes très connus
d'ailleurs souvent le manque de
formation même parfois même de formation
tout court à la base
quand on ne sait ni lire ni compter ce
qui arrive quand même une fraction des
Français aujourd'hui c'est quasiment
impossible de trouver un emploi il est
très content de l'action du Conseil
Général tant mieux
sur le volet social nous on s'est
beaucoup battu sur le volet social parce
qu'on trouve que c'est jamais assez pour
une simple raison et là je sais pas moi
qui vais le dire c'est je vais vous dire
ce qu'a dit la chambre régionale des
comptes en 2012 en 2011 pardon
elle a pointé le Conseil général des
Yvelines comme étant un des départements
des cinq départements qui donnaient le
moins d'aide au social par habitant
pourtant c'est un département qui est
riche donc ce qui est fait au niveau de
l'action sociale et fait au minimum donc
moi je l'ai déjà dit au conseil général
plusieurs fois donc quand c'est moi qui
le dis c'est moi qui le dis mais quand
c'est la chambre régionale des comptes
qui enfonce le clou je pense que on peut
pas douter sur la vérité de ces choses
il y aura de nouveau débats à suivre sur
TVfil 78 avec les candidats sur plaisir
mais aussi sur Saint-Cyr-l'École 10 mars
et 12 mars à 19h extrait résumé dans le
7 8 politique mardi prochain à la même
heure ça c'est aussi pardon que la
rédaction vous proposera de suivre en
direct la soirée électorale le 22 mars
des 20h en partenariat en simultané sur
Radio sensation excellente soirée je
vous retrouve pour le journal du lundi
au vendredi 18h 19h